[Music]
ted nugent has been a rock star for more
than 50 years but he can still talk and
think clearly because he hasn't been
loaded the whole time he's been sober
the whole time and he's one of the
country's most articulate defenders
of our basic constitutional rights in
particular the right to bear arms
he started a group called hunter nation
that organizes people who hunt sportsmen
to stand up for those rights for a brand
new episode chucker carlson today we
spoke at great length to ted nugent and
it was an amazing conversation here's
part of it
i'm in the political
firestorm i've always been
confrontational especially regarding the
second amendment and hunting rights
and i've never been uncomfortable when
they attacked me i go
so so venison is you don't recognize its
value
what do you think deer are here for if
you don't eat them what are they here
for
um
and carrying a gun i would be attacked
for carrying a gun i go
so by the way venison and self-defense
are perfect and you're attacking me
for carrying the gun and killing deer
what are you nuts and of course they
were all stoned
uh
so i i i suppose the inclination would
be uncomfortable when you're attacked
but i i was so confident you may have
noticed this
i'm so confident that the weekend with
my dad and brothers deer hunting
was perfect
literally
perfect yes
balancing the herd participating in
god's miraculous creation as an asset to
bring balance and thriving conditions
and
training aim small miss small
marksmanship i'm a sheriff deputy for
almost 40 years now i train with delta
force tucker get out of here
and so marksmanship and tactical
capabilities to stop evil
could it be anything but perfect yeah
it's literally perfect so my hunting and
my guns
are
perfect and the
beatniks and the hippies would attack me
for those things because if you're
comfortably numb you think peace and
love happened in spite of the trail of
tears in spite of the baton death march
here's a little battle cry i believe in
you pearl harbor me i nagasaki you
[Laughter]
and that keeps us at peace yes the best
way to to keep peace is to be ready to
destroy evil
and if you don't destroy evil it wins
venezuela
cuba
china yeah
democrats
chicago
are you kidding me who doesn't see the
glaring evidence so
i've always known i was in the righteous
camp not because of my opinion of what's
righteous but i consume evidence
i monitor evidence i listen to stories i
see
john belushi got high john belushi's
dead i went hunting i'm still ted um
bad behavior
ugly results cognizant conscientious
behavior happiness
so i and by the way you know
don't confuse comfortably numb with
ultra relaxed
i'm a bow hunter i spend more hours
silent in a tree
than
all humans combined since cochise so
hunter nation
has jumped in where all these alphabet
soup organizations have not and i love
that i'm a member of all of turkey duck
unlimited pheasants white tails what do
you got you got a creature why why the
trout are limited i love it all i bet
you love that i i know them well so so
so hunternation.org
is where it starts if you really go what
do i do what do i do go to
hunternation.org
and see what we're doing because it's
not about hunting really it's about god
family country and the traditional
values that make people
take their lives into their own hands to
get here
because there's this unique freedom that
is guaranteed by those sacred documents
and again those are just documents the
freedom is already here
i was born with the right to keep and
bear arms
i was born with the right to speak up i
was born with the right to privacy from
my government intrusion without just
cause i was born with that
i could come here naked without any
constitution and i know i could say what
i want to say i don't have to get the
king's permission
kings emperors tyrants kiss my
we are a self-government
we are in charge we hire people to
represent us based on these self-evident
truths and if you if you infringe on
them we will fire your and don't make us
arrest you
man is ted nugent an interesting person
to talk to a ball of energy and a very
clear thinker and a good guy went on for
more than an hour you can find the full
episode
tucker carlson today on fox nation
available right now
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else